why did communism fail you started to
say
that
conservatives criticized it on on the
basis of like rationalism that you're
throwing away the past you're starting
from scratch is that the fundamental
description of why communism failed i
think the fundamental difference between
rationalists and empiricists is the
question of whether you're throwing away
the past
that's the argument and it cashes out as
a distinction between
abstract universal rationalist political
theories
and uh empirical political theories
empirical political theories are are
they're always going to say something
like um
look
there are many different societies
we can say that some are better and some
are worse
but the problem is that
you know that that
there are many different ways in which a
society can be better or worse
there's an ongoing competition and we're
learning on an ongoing basis what are
the ways in which societies can be
better and worse
that creates a kind of i'd say a mild
skepticism a moderate skepticism among
conservatives i don't think too many
conservatives have a problem looking at
the
at the soviet union which is brutal and
murderous ineffective in its
economics totally ineffective you know
spiritually and then collapsed okay so
so so i think it's easier for us to look
at a system like that
and say you know what on earth what what
should we learn from that
but the main conservative tradition is
pretty tolerant of a diversity of
different kinds of society and is slow
to insist that france is so tyrannical
it just needs a revolution because
what's going to come after the
revolution is going to be much better
the assumption is that there's lots of
things that are
good about most societies and that a a
clean slate leads you to
to throw out all the inherited things
that that
you don't even know how to notice until
they're gone could i actually play
devil's advocate here and address
something you've also said
can we as opposed to knowing the
empirical data of the 20th century that
communism presented can we go back to
the beginning of the 20th century
can you empathize or steal man or put
yourself in a place
of the soviet union where the workers
are being disrespected
and
can you not see that the conservatives
could be pro-communism
like communism is such a strongly
negative word in modern day political
discourse that you can't like you have
to put yourself
in the mind of
uh people who like red colors
who like that's what it was it was
it's all about the branding i think
um just but also like the ideas of
solidarity
of nation
of togetherness
of uh respect for fellow man i mean all
these things that kind of communist
represents can you not see
that this idea
uh is actually uh
going along with conservatism it is in
some ways respecting the the deep ideals
of the past
but proposing a new way
to raise those ideals
implement those ideas in the system yes
i'm gonna try to do it what you're
suggesting but historically we actually
have a more useful option i think for
both of our positions instead of you
know pretending that we like the actual
communists uh we we have conservative
statesmen like uh disraeli and bismarck
who initiated
um uh social legislation right the the
the
uh the the first step towards saying
uh look we're one nation we're
undergoing industrialization
that industrialization is
important and positive but it's also
doing
a lot of damage to a lot of people and
in particular it's doing damage not just
to individuals and families but it's
it's doing damage to the to the social
fabric the capacity of britain or german
to remain cohesive societies is being
harmed
and so it's these two conservative
statesmen israeli and bismarck who who
actually take the first steps uh in
order to legislate for you know for what
today we would consider to be minimal
social programs uh pensions and
disability insurance and those kinds of
things so for sure conservatives
do look at industrialization as a rapid
change and they say
we we do have to care about the nation
as a whole and we have to care about it
as a unity and and i assume that euron
will say
look that's the first step towards the
the the catastrophe of communism
but
before your own drives that nail into
the car
let me try to make a distinction because
when you read marx
you're reading an intellectual
descendant of descartes
you're reading somebody who says um
look
every society has
uh consists of oppressors and oppressed
right and and and that's an improvement
in some ways over liberal thinking
because at least he's seeing he's seeing
groups as a as a a real social
phenomenon but he says every society has
a oppressor class and oppressed class
there are different classes they're
different groups and whenever one is
stronger it exploits the ones that are
weaker
all right
that is the the foundation
of a revolutionary
political theory why because the moment
that you say
that the only relationship between
the stronger and the weaker is
exploitation
the moment that you say that then you're
pushed into the position and marx and
angle say this explicitly you're pushed
into the position we're saying when will
the exploitation end
never until there's a revolution what
happens when there's a revolution you
eliminate the oppressor class it's an
annihilationist i mean you you can
immediately when you read it see why
it's different from from uh descartes or
bismarck because they're trying to keep
everybody you know somehow at peace with
one another and marx is saying there is
no peace that oppressor class has to be
annihilated and and then they go ahead
and do it and they in the and they kill
100 million people so i i do think that
despite the fact your question is is
good and right there are certain
similarities in concern but still i
think you can tell the difference
between that extra step of revolution to
you is where the problem comes like that
extra step of let's kill all the
oppressors
that's the problem right and then to you
you're on the whole step one is the
problem well it's all a problem b first
i don't view communism as um
something that radical in a sense that i
i think it it comes from a tradition of
collectivism i think it comes from a
tradition of looking at groups and and
measuring things in terms of groups
it comes from tradition where you expect
some people to be sacrificed for the
greater good of the of the whole
uh i i think it comes from a tradition
where
mysticism uh or
as as the source of of truth
is accepted i view marx as in some sense
very christian i i i don't think he's
this radical rejecting i i think he's
just reformatting uh christianity in a
sense he's replacing in a sense he's
replacing god with the proletarian uh
knowledge you know you have to you have
to get knowledge from somewhere so you
need the dictatorship of the palestinian
you need somebody the stalin the lenin
who who somehow communes with the spirit
the the spirit of the proletarian
there's no rationality not rationalism
there's no rationality in marx
there is a lot of mysticism and there is
a lot of uh hand waving and there's a
lot of sacrifice and a lot of original
sin in the way he views humanity
you